este chaleco antibalas está diseñado
para niños está hecho para ti quepan las
mochilas escolares para que los niños lo
lleven en todo momento su creador un
jefe de bomberos de arizona dice que la
ausencia de cambios con la política de
armas en eeuu y el repunte de tiroteos
masivos hacen que su producto sea una
triste necesidad
es muy trágico que estas cosas sigan
ocurriendo y por desgracia probablemente
van a seguir ocurriendo así que ya sabes
estoy tratando de hacer que mi producto
esté tan disponible como pueda y que se
difunda solo para dar a la gente una
herramienta más para tratar de proteger
a sus hijos y sus familias
el chaleco tiene placas antibalas
delanteras y traseras y está fabricado
con materiales ligeros diseñados para
hacerlo más compacto es posible y
proteger todos los órganos vitales se
presenta como un chaleco plegable o un
escudo que hace que cualquier mochila
sea a prueba de balas aunque las
reacciones a este producto han sido
varias
creo que es algo que me gustaría que
tuvieran sabes creo que definitivamente
estamos en esos tiempos en los que
tenemos que preocuparnos por la
seguridad de nuestros hijos mucho más de
lo que pensábamos
no creo que el chaleco sea realmente
necesario el niño todavía tiene que
correr tienes que lograr escapar de un
atacante que dispara a la cabeza tienes
que poder escapar skate el mes pasado 19
niños y 2 profesores fueron asesinados
en oval de texas en el tiroteo más
mortífero en una escuela en una década
según la organización sin ánimo de lucro
gun violence archive este año se han
producido al menos 239 tiroteos masivos
en eeuu